gabrielle union was devastated and
broken into pieces after learning that
her now husband dwyane wade had a baby
with another woman for the first time
ever the actress speaks out about the
life-changing moment in her new memoir
you got anything stronger love wasn't
some guy riding up on a white horse and
you know you live in a castle and it's
happily ever after gabrielle recalls
quote in 2013 before we were married
dwayne had a baby with another woman it
should go without saying that we were
not in a good place in our relationship
at the time that child was conceived but
we were in a much better place when he
finally told me about the pregnancy i
have not had words and even after untold
amounts of therapy i am not sure i have
them now but truth matters the actress
and the former basketball player began
dating in 2008. the athlete fathered now
seven-year-old xavier in 2013 when he
and gabrielle were on a break when
dwayne broke the news to her they were
trying for their own child she wrote the
experience of dwayne having a baby so
easily while i was unable to left my
soul not just broken into pieces but
shattered into fine dust scattering in
the wind with desperate hands we
gathered what we could to slowly remake
me into something new gabrielle hit rock
bottom while going through a couple
miscarriages saying she remembered
thinking
this woman is such a failure and she has
the nerve to be old and she has the
nerve to have a younger husband and she
has the nerve to stick with a guy who
had a kid with somebody else she
admitted that her feelings weren't
originating from a healthy place during
that time what happens in your family
shapes so much of how you see the world
the decisions you make on the people you
allow in your life
you know how you interact with other
people amid her rocky road to motherhood
she recalled the former miami heat
player telling her as much as we want
this baby i want you we've lost too much
in our relationship for me to be okay
with encouraging you to do one more
thing to your body and your soul he
motivates me he has like every day i
feel like i wake up and he's got a new
deal on the table so it makes me go okay
let's keep working let's keep striving
um you know i married a guy almost 10
years younger than me and i i assumed i
would be the teacher and here i am the
people learning um you know and being
motivated by by his work ethic but
despite the unconditional love from her
partner gabrielle wasn't certain they
would make it through the dark time
writing so much of what made the
decision so difficult was that if i
didn't submit to surrogacy then i was
convinced i needed to let dwayne go
even if he didn't want to i had to let
him find someone who could give him what
he wanted but i loved him ultimately she
chose love and surrogacy welcoming the
couple's daughter kavia in november
2016. she added each day he had work to
be forgiven and i had chosen to love him
and forgive him and part of this journey
of making peace with our love is also
making peace with ourselves i've learned
to open keeping my mind open keep my
eyes open keep my heart open and keep my
thoughts open and that's what i've been
trying to do is i'm grown into
the man that i've always dreamed of
becoming the actress noted the pair's
relationship struggles made them
stronger writing he wouldn't have become
the man he desperately wanted to be and
i would not become the woman i dreamed
of being but admits the me of today
would not have stayed with him
[Music]
the couple meanwhile celebrated their
seven-year wedding anniversary last
month and although dwayne and gabrielle
went through tough times they came out
on top together
[Music]
you